so welcome everyone to this first
session
bioinformatics from infectious diseases
and thank you for
registering already on the learn portal
and also
uh joining our webinar today and
hopefully everybody that has joined has
shared their
background information in the recent
poll that somalica shared
so a little bit about the program before
i start today's session
today's session will be a glimpse of
what kinds of topics and projects we're
going to be focusing on throughout the
program but also
we'll do some hands-on exercises that
everybody can
learn from about next-generation
sequencing data analysis
overall the program is going to be
focused on viral
bacterial and parasite infections
and the host response to those
infections and we're going to be
looking at bioinformatics methods that
will allow us to study these topics
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is an online training program
we've done it already several times but
i think that the relevant
the relevancy of these methods is
increasing and decreasing so we're
excited about
many of you joining this program and
hopefully today's
session will give you a clear
understanding of how this program will
work
so as a result of this program you will
be able to understand
the pathogens from a genomics
perspective
being able to identify them in animal
reservoirs vectors
and hosts and understand how to apply
analysis methods to study viral
evolution replication and adaptation
and then we'll also talk about bacterial
and parasite infections and how they
are different from viral infections as
well as how we can
apply some similar methods to study them
and understand their
complexity of the infection that they
cause in the variation in the disease
as a result of that infection we'll talk
about
how to detect viral genomes in
next-generation sequencing data
so we'll look at methods today where we
can take
next-generation sequencing data of all
rna or total rna
and then identify specific pathogens and
also validate that we are indeed finding
viral genomes
we'll talk about different strains and
haplotypes how to determine
what kinds of genomes we are finding
we'll also talk about the application of
such methods to vaccine design
antiviral drug design and antibiotics
and we'll look at some epidemiological
trends and drug resistance
that are applicable to mycobacterium
tuberculosis
malaria and some other pathogens
so the important part of this program is
that the program itself
is a project driven program so we'll be
talking about different methods
different applications but we'll take
examples of real data sets that you can
find on
ncbi uh gis aid and other repositories
specific to different types of pathogens
and we will do a little bit of that
today so you'll get a sense of where you
can find some data sets that might be
interesting to you that might be
related to the topic of your research
and we'll also take a look at some of
the curated examples that we provide
on our portal that will provide you with
a launch port so you can start with your
analysis with your research project in a
very fast way
before i continue let me briefly talk a
little bit about myself
as somalica already mentioned my name is
elia brodsky and i've had a
an experience with hundreds of students
across many campuses
supporting training in bioinformatics
and
helping students with minimal
bioinformatic background
apply methods of big data analysis to
data sets that are
interesting and relevant to their
research
and so i've had the privilege of running
hundreds of online and on-site programs
related to bioinformatics with our
collaborators
at georgetown university louisiana state
university tulane university of haifa
and many others
and as a result i've seen hundreds of
students from all backgrounds
complete their training and get
empowered by bioinformatics tools
to participate in various research
studies so it's always exciting for me
to see how
someone that might have a research idea
and is
trained to use bioinformatics tools in a
good way
is then able to contribute to a real
research problem and
the most exciting of these projects are
translational research projects that end
up
uh leading to important changes in human
health and disease
and so what i hope for you in this
program is that
these resources and this kind of
training can also be helpful to you and
we're also looking to learn from you
uh to understand better what might be
most relevant to you and most
interesting to you as well and how do
you think we can improve these programs
by adding additional resources
or providing you with one-on-one
mentorship
which i will talk about in a little bit
so um to kind of get started we recently
had
a free webinar where we discussed some
of the applications of next generation
sequencing
to viral infections to different types
of infectious diseases
so let me start by kind of recapping
some of those topics and this will give
you an idea of
in general where this program is headed
so as you know in the last
20 years one of the things that has
changed drastically
is how easy it is to acquire genomic
data and and there are multiple factors
because of that so some of the factors
relate to how cheap it is to generate
next generation sequencing data
there is a growing community of experts
that
are comfortable sharing their data more
and more so researchers and
research labs are easily sharing this
data with others
there is also a growing community of
experts that can easily generate such
data which makes it
much easier to go to different remote
places around the world
generate high quality data and really
ask questions about
different aspects of infectious diseases
so in application to
viral bacterial as well as
parasite-caused infectious diseases this
is a growing resource that i think
many of us can leverage as we see what's
happening around us like the pandemic
right now
but also learn about other challenges to
human health and disease and so
what this program is designed to do is
kind of give you a sense of how
different types of omics data could be
used
to understand and ask questions
about different pathogens that you might
be
aware of that you might be interested
you might be researching
and it applies to analysis of genomic
data
transcriptomic data as well as
structural data so we'll talk a little
bit about these examples
throughout the whole program and today
we'll talk about one aspect of that
we'll talk about next generation
sequencing data analysis to find their
viral pathogens but in general
it applies to viral genomics and
evolution
microbiome and infection it also applies
to immune response biomarkers on the
host side using transcriptomic data
analysis
it applies to drug resistance population
genetics to understand
diversity in pathogens that are causing
disease
and in genome-wide association studies
where we can
measure the relationship between genomic
variants
and phenotypes that we can capture
so we'll talk about all of these things
throughout the program but before we
begin
so malika already mentioned that to
really participate in today's session
and make the most out of the time that
we have together
we need to first get set up with the
program
and with the omixlogic portal so
let me kind of take you through those
steps again
maybe i could ask in the chat how many
of you have
already registered on the omixlogic
portal
so maybe if you have registered you can
put number one
and then if you have not put
zero and if you
are putting zero don't even put zero
just go to this link
and create a free account so it's really
free of cost and without this account
you will not be able to do the practical
steps that we will do in just a little
bit and i don't want to
wait for everyone okay so if you are
having trouble
registering if you could please
email us so you can email marketing
at pine dot io and please specify
what exactly is the problem that you're
seeing so maybe a screenshot
or what is your browser anything like
that so if you have not
okay the site is just blank so maybe
you could let suraj know and see what
could be done about that so please use
google chrome if you can if it is not
loading for you
maybe turn on the private window and try
again
okay and i'm actually getting
notifications as you're signing up so i
see that
uh quite a number of you are signing up
so i'm just going to give it
just two more minutes and i'll explain
how this is relevant to what we will be
doing today
so first of all you will see here on the
site
what are the specific things that we are
using
in these programs and these include some
online
training resources like tutorials i'm
not going to be going through a tutorial
today but you will see them on your own
we'll be talking about the logic of
analysis how to prepare specific
pipelines that allow us to analyze big
data
okay if you cannot sign in there's
actually a reset password
place where you can
reset your password if i go to log in
you can see right here send password
reset so you can use that to reset your
password
all right so um again what are
what are some of the things that we will
leverage in today's session
we will use the pipeline builder when
you create an account on the portal
you will also get your password and that
password could be used on this portal so
we will go there in just a few minutes
some of the methods that we will be
using today
are based on scripts in r and python and
so you'll find here some tutorials
and i'll briefly speak about that in
just a few minutes
and then we'll also talk about some
curated data sets that you will be able
to use
now this program is about infectious
diseases but those of you that
are not interested in infectious
diseases and have some other topic that
you might be interested in
we recommend trying out some of these
other tracks
so you can see some of those here
once you're logged in i just want to
briefly take you to
the infectious diseases program page so
that you can understand
how that works so you can go to the
programs
right here and you will see that
this is a program that i am already a
part of if you're not a part of this
program
you can still see here some information
you won't be able to see
everything but if you have not logged in
yet
you can explore some of the topics that
we will be covering
and so this is how it's going to work
you will see here several important
aspects like
the overview of the program which
includes also the schedule
you'll see the courses that are included
and here's some of the courses that we
are going to be using throughout this
whole program
you will also see that you can book a
meeting
so this is a meeting that you can
schedule with a mentor
right now it is with sonalika who is our
community manager
but once the program continues after
today's session
we're going to have here an opportunity
for you to set up a one-on-one meeting
with one of the mentors and i'll
introduce one of the mentors today dr
creek or when you book a meeting
you have to have uh that level of
subscription
so later on dr mohit mizunder we'll talk
about different levels
that you can access and how those vary
by the features that you will get
as a result of your registration also we
have a slack
channel okay so those of you that are
joining
the program you will be getting an email
with all of the details
of about the different resources that
you will have
and here you will see that the questions
that you will have in the future
about any of the topics that we discuss
will be
discussed right here and it will be
visible both
both on this page and in slack itself
so maybe you could add here
all of the participants already and
once you complete the requirements of
this program which will include
some theoretical practical and hands-on
sessions
you will get a certificate of completion
so that certificate of completion is
something that you'll be able to
download it will have
your name here it will have the program
training director as well as the date
right here
and once you have completed those you
can download this it will also show up
on your profile so please take a look
here as well
we also have options for certificates of
excellence certificates of excellence
are issued for those that are
going beyond the minimal so they are
actually interested in developing their
own independent research projects and so
this is something that please take some
time to
study and then we'll cover this a little
bit more now
right here you can see that i have
created my own profile i've changed my
profile image i've made sure that my
name is spelled correctly all of these
are important because it will be
featured on your certificate
and you can also see that i have some
points
and these points are going to be
important for you to go through the
program and make sure that we are aware
of the things that you are completing
and so please take a look here you will
see some achievements
courses that you've completed the
lessons that you've completed
the individual steps and also code
blocks that you will be running
inside the training modules
so as you can see this is my profile
now you will see here i've started
posting some questions that you can see
at the bottom there of the page and
here are some of the courses that are
included in this program so these
courses are going to give you
an introduction but also provide you
with the context for the different
project data sets that we're going to be
leveraging throughout this program
if you ever go to the main page you will
be able to search for them so for
example if you're interested in the
ebola virus just search for ebola and
you will see that the recommendation
will be
included right here what are some of the
project data sets that we will be
using in this program we'll talk about
the origins and pathogenesis of the
novel coronavirus so we'll talk about
some hypotheses out there where it has
originated
and some of the methodology of how we
can ask questions about
origins and what are some of the tools
that we have to
find such information in the next
generation sequencing data
available online we'll talk about
tuberculosis
a disease that affects many millions of
people around the world
and is raising concern because of drug
resistant mycobacterium tuberculosis
then we need to categorize and identify
to be able to find
appropriate treatments for this kind of
emerging
resistant strains of tuberculosis we'll
use
ebola virus as one of our examples as
well
because the genomic sequencing
revolution in the area of infectious
diseases
really started with the epidemic in
2014 2016 for the ebola virus
in west africa and this is an example
of a an epidemic that rapidly spread
attracted the visibility and attention
of teams from around the world that
basically
went there and started sequencing the
viral and the host
samples to understand the spread and the
potential
disease that this virus is going to
cause
we'll also talk about some advanced
methods of ultra deep sequencing where
we can identify
low frequency mutations and study
populations of haplotypes within the
host
and we'll also talk about some examples
of how we can apply
the same methods to track novel emerging
pathogens
that are appearing in host
transcriptomes
so to talk about all of these topics
today is one of the sessions that we
will cover
many starting points that are going to
be relevant for the rest of the program
so if you're joining
just to learn about the program i think
you probably have enough information
of what it's going to look like and now
we're going to transition to some
practical hands-on exercises so that
we can understand the data and then
start asking about different questions
from next generation sequencing data
so today i'll introduce you to next
generation sequencing
and talk a little bit about one example
of what you can do with this kind of
data
so as you know the viro
is one part of the microbiome and it
constitutes
all of the organisms that inhabit us so
all of the microorganisms that live in
our gut in our lungs
in our mouth everywhere those
could be divided into bacteria fungi but
also
viruses and so when we talk about all of
the viruses that are present in our body
a lot of these viruses are actually
harmless to
human beings they might affect the
bacteria so they could be
maybe even beneficial in some sense
because they control
bacterial composition but they also
could
find their way into places that are not
intended for them that are not prepared
for them and so
a lot of times when we speak about all
of the viruses that are present
in the host we can call it the viron
now the size of the mammalian birom is
actually not known
although our own cells are outnumbered
by our bacterial microbiome the number
of viruses may be even
10 times higher still than the
microbiome
human feces alone contain about 10 to
the 8
to 10 to the nine viruses per gram
and the mammalian viral is continuously
updated through rapid evolution of
viruses and through exposure to viruses
in the environment or in other mammals
and so
because there's such diversity we have
seen
an increase in the number of viruses
that are studied from their genomic
perspective so
we can see that primarily the viruses
that are being characterized
and studied using genomic sequencing are
the viruses that cause disease
even though there are many viruses out
there a lot of them are harmless
and the ones that we see a lot of new
data coming out
is always about the viruses that cause
disease
and so one of the primary repositories
for viral
genomes is called the national
center for biotechnology information
ncbi
and one of the portions of ncbi is
called the genbank so this is
an area on ncbi where all of these viral
genomes
are deposited so if we just take a look
at
the current pandemic you can see that
the number of genomic
sequences associated with the source
code 2
has been growing exponentially in a much
faster pace than many of the
other viruses in previous pandemics so
you can see
if we compare the number of genomes per
month
available on ncbi for sars one
it was just a few genomes per month for
ebola as i mentioned
one of the times that we saw in this
dramatic
increases in the number of genomic
sequences available
it was over five genomes per month if we
take the range of the whole pandemic
2014 to 2016.
and then for coca-19 this is data i
believe from 2020
you can see that the number of genomes
per month that is made available on
ncbi is continuing to grow at
a dramatic pace and what that tells us
is that this
area of viral next generation sequencing
is a promising area of infectious
disease research
that is going to be driven by next
generation sequencing
technologies and these technologies are
also evolving
and changing as we move on so
to talk a little bit about what they are
i think one of the
major challenges in next generation
sequencing
is the amount of computational analysis
that has to be done
to extract meaningful information from
this type of
detailed data collection method so
typically the data is collected
from a biological sample and then
there's an
instrument called a sequencer that
actually generates the
data the digital data and then in
between our
ability to analyze this data we have to
what's called
process this data so we have to run
bioinformatics pipelines
that allow us to extract some meaning
from
the collection of digital data that
these instruments produce
now the instruments are sequencers
but they take in different types of
biological samples and these biological
samples could be
prepared in different ways they could be
targeted sequencing
where library preparation techniques
amplify
for a specific pathogen or a specific
gene
using primers they could be total dna
and rna
where we use specific primers to
focus on a particular type of
for example dna or rna we can take
ribosomal
amplification we can use depletion but
ultimately
we are trying to focus on one
for example the host the human dna or
the human rna
and we are able to
[Music]
look at all of the variation of that
host
okay if somebody cannot see the screen
um
i'm sorry about that maybe you could
rejoin and
um for me it's saying that i am showing
the stream
now the other approach is to look at
amplicon
or environmental type sequences so the
way that works
is we actually take a look at specific
type of rna for example the 16s
ribosomal rna would allow us to study
diversity and composition
of bacterial samples present
in our environmental sample so to learn
about this
we have prepared a collection of
articles that talk about different
sequencing methods and approaches
and we will share those links on the
slack channel after today's session so
if anyone is interested
to learn more we will be providing some
literature
and you will be able to continue and
expand your knowledge about
different techniques for different types
of
methods of sequencing let me take a look
at some of the questions here
when we take targeted sequence and when
we take total dna rna okay so that's a
good question today we're going to look
at
one of the examples and so when we look
at that example you'll kind of see the
use case for
different types of techniques is this
applicable in the philippines
i believe this is this is an online
program so anyone from around the world
can join
and practice using the same tool so if
your internet connection is stable
and if you're able to join our meetings
live like today
or view the recorded sessions you can
also do that
on your own time
so when we speak about viral or
bacterial sequencing
a lot of times we can look at
either strains that we can grow in back
in the lab where we can identify
specific variation in bacterial
genomic data of
a strain or multiple strains right so
that's the objective and that
is called culture-based sequencing so
we essentially grow the bacteria in a
culture and then
those cultured bacteria could be
sequenced and we can perform genomic
analysis
of that dna sometimes
we don't know the bacteria that we're
looking for
and we're interested in looking at the
whole composition so we're interested to
look at
the different types of bacteria that are
present and so
that's when we use culture free
sequencing methods or
environmental sequences and then we can
classify them we can organize them by
their taxonomic belongings so where are
they
in the taxonomy and what are the
differences in composition between
different samples
okay so may is asking when we use 16s
rna do we target only living bacteria
yes typically you take a sample from a
bacterial sample that is either living
or
it could be dead bacteria of course the
rna is going to degrade
for a long time so you have to preserve
it somehow but
then when you sequence you can extract
different types of information
16s ribosomal rna you can extract
taxonomy
for all whole rna or dna you can
actually look at the complete genome and
all the variants from other
types of bacteria now when it comes to
viruses
it's a little bit different we can also
look at
specific viral samples
to understand what are the prevalent
species in the data that we collected
for example if we use a sample from
a an infected patient we can then ask
the question how is a particular virus
infecting this patient
different from the reference that we
have
or sometimes we can actually look at
the whole rna in dna from the host
and ask the question what kinds of
viruses are actually
present in a given sample in the given
patient right
so those are two very different
questions but we can still
look at those two perspectives to really
understand
how this works now to give you
a practical example let me introduce you
to a resource
for metagenomic sequence and we'll use
this as our first
exercise so if you go on the learn
portal
right here to courses and you search for
metagenomics
here we have some introductory course
material where you will find information
on
how microbiome sequencing is done what
is the microbiome
role in human health how do you
visualize 16s ribosomal rna metagenomic
data
how do you analyze it for uh composition
and things like that and so here you
will see a lot of coursework that you
can go through
to learn about different methods of
annotation of such
next generation sequencing data for
microbiome composition
studies okay now from this
example we're going to look at just one
of those examples we're not going to
look at microbiome samples we're
actually going to look at a host sample
that contains a viral genome
and to do that and this is one of the
exercises that you will find here
but to do that we are going to go
to the t by unfor platform and this way
all of you can participate
in the hands-on assignment that we will
do together
so please go with me to this link and
let me know once you are logged in
so if you're logged in you will see that
your name should be over here
and to log in you will be able to use
the same password that you registered
with
on the learnomicslogic.com portal
so if you have your account and you're
signed in
please put number one in the chat box
and i'll give a few minutes to everyone
to log in if you have not created an
account yet
then you can create an account really
quickly and just use the same password
so may maybe you could take a look at
creating an account on learn
on xlogic.com it's a free process
and then you'll be able to use that here
as well
okay because the same thing if you could
create an account then you will be able
to follow along
i'll just give it 30 more seconds
all right great so the first
thing that we will do is we will
actually take a look at this
first section right here and there's a
drop down
right here where you can see
how we will take a sample from a host
you will see this demo sf9 on map reads
we are taking here a total rna
sequencing data
from the host and so you can click on
start oh
sorry not this one i have this demo
let's go to this
first demo okay and we'll take a look at
the host data i'm going to click on
start
bowtie 2g
and visualization okay
and so we will just take a look at what
is this data look like
okay now if you are logged in i'm just
going to be able to
i think give you this link and if you
didn't create the same pipeline you just
click on this link and go there from
your computer
and then we can click on this link
called visualization
and so this is uh this is
jbrowse so this is a browser
that allows us to see individual
sequencing reads
okay so here you can see these little
dots these are actually reads
okay so if we zoom in
you'll start seeing that each one of
these you can click on them
and you can see that this is a read it
contains a
quality score for each letter
in the sequence and here's the actual
sequence
so the reads are 150 nucleotides long
this is the actual sequence of each weed
and this is their quality
and down below here if you get out of
that window you will see the coverage
so what is coverage the coverage is just
the amount of reads
per position or over here you can
actually see the stack that reads
okay let's repeat the procedure again
together
all right so just so that i know how
many of you are following along
so if you're following along let me know
and chat
we'll see how many of you are still here
i'm going to go right here to demo
rnaseq cell line project
all right thank you petra once you're
here you'll see that
the buttons start highlighting the
methods that you can select so the first
thing that we need to do to start the
pipeline
click on start now the pipeline is for
rna-seq data analysis
okay so cool free you need to just log
in
once you're logged in you go to
areas of analysis click on this drop
down
select this demo pipeline
click on start and now you see several
options highlight
so the highlighted options are the
different types of pipelines that you
can run on this data
and the one that we want to do is we
want to map
the data that we have this is total rna
sequencing
map it on the host genome so that's why
we'll use bowtie2g
and then we'll visualize the produced
bam files
so these files contain all of the start
and
and the actual sequence of reads that we
have in our data
so click on visualization
and then you can complete your pipeline
so that means your pipeline is ready
so once your pipeline is ready you'll
have this link
for visualization
okay so amartya just making sure have
you been able to
to run this pipeline
hello sd yes good to see you here as
well
okay so now you have this link for
visualization you
click on visualization and you will see
the reads
stacked up aligned to the reference
genome so right here you see
the reference genome on top what is this
reference genome
okay so if you click right here you'll
see that there are many
different things here mentioned right
what is this
if you actually take this you can see on
ncbi
what this is so let's go to ncbi
and right here we can just search for
this
okay what is this this is spot of terror
frugiperda
it's a uh okay
so it's a whole genome so this is
something that we can
uh read a little bit more over here
sf9 is a cell line that is used for
production of different biologics so
when they make different proteins like
insulin or different vaccines even a lot
of times
they're grown in insect cells
and these insect cells can also get
infected by viruses
and so a major concern is when we see
viruses that could also cause human
infection because if you produce
vaccines or biologics that are
later on used to treat people but they
have contamination
it's a huge concern and so this example
that we're doing together
is from an fda for
the nih uh kind of uh dealing with fda
projects that are concerned with
contamination in these kinds of cell
line cultures
and so what they have found is that
these cell lines could get contaminated
and the question is with what kinds of
viruses
so the first thing that we can do is we
can map the reeds
onto the reference genome and the second
thing that we can do
in our pipeline is we can actually look
at
all of our data and get from this data
information about reads that are not
mapped to the reference genome okay so
now let's go to another section
and now we can analyze the data
where we take all of the unmapped reads
and map them onto a database of all the
viruses
okay so we're gonna go right here
again on the areas of analysis
go to metagenomics microbiome and we're
going to go to
sf9 mapping on viral database
okay so we're going to map the reads
onto the viral database
and see what kind of viruses we can
actually find
so to go to bow tie to align
pause count names replace
and and now we will get some
files okay
so the file you want to take from here
is this one
sf9 not map database viruses table after
annotation
once we take this file
what do we see in this data set
just open excel real quick
okay so here we have
viral genomes you can see again they're
from ncbi
mapped to from these reads right so some
of these reads
map this uh to uh some of these viral
genomes
okay and saera is asking how this demo
will help us prepare for original
projects
well before you start your original
project you have to know what you're
doing and so all of the methods that
we're doing today
are demo because we don't have to deal
with uploading data
and thinking about what kind of analysis
to do
we're actually going to use some of
these curated examples
but once you're trained and you
understand how this analysis is done
then you can go and find your own data
and perform similar analysis because
now you know what it does and what kind
of inputs and
outputs are required to be able to run
this kind of analysis
okay so just briefly i'm going to sort
this
sorry from largest to smallest and i can
see that
the largest one that has over uh
100 000 rings is this genome
right so i can go and check what kind of
a genome
is this so
here go to
all databases and look for this gene
again you can see that one of the more
abundant
genomes is this uh
granulovirus okay and this granola virus
is something that we actually expect to
find because it is
being used in the actual production
using these cell lines right
so this kind of gives you a sense of
how do you actually take sequencing data
which is digital data about some
biological process
that is captured in real time and then
analyze this data using
different methods and tools to be able
to extract some
meaningful information it's structured
right you can ask questions
about this data and so using such
examples
today is the first session so we're
obviously not doing
a lot of finding new data sets and
looking for different types of
analysis that we can do we can start
understanding
what does this data represent and
how can we actually analyze this data
and get some meaningful insights
so now is the time if you have any
questions
let's talk about what kind of questions
you might have about what we just
covered
so again what did we cover we covered
different applications of
next-generation sequencing data
to study infectious diseases including
bacterial
pathogen from parasites and viral
diseases
so these types of diseases all could be
studied using next generation sequencing
data and in this
uh program we will talk about different
methods of analysis
provide you with examples and show you
where to find
data that you could use to prepare
independent projects
number two we talked about resources
that you can find
that explain the methods of analysis
that explain
give the context for different projects
and also
how you can interact with all of us the
mentors of this program
so that you can ask questions and get
help
with your independent project number
three
we talked about some of the tools that
we have
and some of the tools include some of
the methods of analysis that you just
saw me demonstrate
that show you how to use the methods for
big data analysis and how to use some of
the examples that we had prepared
and also we talked about how to
use downstream analysis methods for data
visualization
and statistical analysis in r and python
and so
at the end of today's session we will
actually show you how to do that as well
on the learnomicslogic.com portal
but okay so um
there's a question about the recording
yes you will get the recording and the
recording is already available on our
youtube channel
so let me just briefly show you how this
will work in the program itself
for those of you that are already
registered
you can see this is today's session and
right here
you can see this session video so this
video
is already a recording of today's
session so you can just see it right
here